that's probably the most fun I've had on
a movie again early in my career 20s but
a big cast of people in the same place I
want to have his adopted babies
the cast was very connected
hey
hey I'm not stupid oh
looks like you're seeing double
he's good right leaving was
heartbreaking it truly was like the
first time I was like I mean I can just
hang out guys if you need me to you know
I'd see you don't want to miss a beat
another film where there was a rehearsal
period that was more physical based you
know a lot of people had action
sequences I had to learn how to
skateboard but the rehearsal was so fun
then you leave and come back a month
later to do your bit and you just have
such horrible fomo you just you know
what you guys been doing have you ever
been having fun send me pictures yeah to
this day that email chain is still very
active